[Music]
[Music]
good morning to you it's seven o'clock
you're watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster and this morning a
mission statement to protect us from
future pandemics but new questions about
covet problems of the present plenty to
talk about with the business secretary
who's on the program shortly plus we'll
be joined by the man
in charge of the nova vaxx trial after
the news that the uk has signed a deal
to manufacture 60 million doses
also the six-month window calls for
victims of domestic abuse to be given
more time to report crimes before the
chance of prosecution elapses
a half past eight will speak to a
survivor alongside
labour's jess phillips and at the
quarter tonight we meet the retired
dorset plumber
who's rocking the world of fossil
hunting
it is tuesday the 30th of march
nobody is safe until everyone is safe
the prime minister joins world leaders
calling for an international treaty to
fight
pandemics don't let your concerns be the
thing that widens racial inequality in
our society
seleni henry joins celebrities calling
on black communities to have their kovid
vaccine
protests at day one of the trial of the
former police officer
accused of murdering george floyd we
speak to the floyd family lawyer
everybody is saying this is your
opportunity america
to show us that you are the beacon
of hope and justice when it comes to
equality and justice fall
fleeing for their lives we're with the
refugees escaping over the border from
the violence
in myanmar how the pandemic began
sky news sees a draft report of the
world health organization's take
on the origins of kobit 19 we'll reveal
what it says and yesterday we saw
the highest temperature of the year so
far but today we are likely to beat it
as it will be
widely warm and sunny but still wet and
cold across northwest scotland i'll have
the details for you later
a very good morning to you nobody is
safe until
everyone is safe that's a warning from
world leaders this morning
calling for an international treaty to
fight future pandemics
they say it's a case of not if but when
the uk is amongst 24 world leaders and
the director general of the world health
organization
calling for a post-world war ii style
treaty to protect future generations
meanwhile boris johnson has announced up
to 60 million doses of the novovax
vaccine will be manufactured in the uk
and a group of high-profile stars led by
seleni henry
have penned an open letter encouraging
black communities
to get a vaccine it comes after figures
from the office for national statistics
taken from the 13th of january
to the 7th of february showed less than
half of black or black british adults
said they were likely to have the
vaccine ally fortescue reports
dear moms and dads familiar faces
dispatch to dispel
this information nephews nieces
while other communities are rushing to
get the vaccine and millions have
already been vaccinated
some black people in our community are
being more cautious
seleni henry is leading the host of
household names
writing an open letter and releasing
this video asking black britons to trust
the covid vaccine
we love you a direct appeal to
communities where
uptake is low but will it work there's
no celebrity out there that's going to
affect my judgment this is basically
what information i take in and then i'll
just make my judgment of that
would you take it yes no and why we're
talking to people
in north london with nhs doctor amica
the vaccine's a blessing
and i think slowly the more uptick we
see especially from our communities
from you know black and asian and
minority ethnic people the faster we're
going to get out of this pandemic at
this point
no i wouldn't take it okay we just
ignored it we just ignored
this information he's seen firsthand the
impact
not being vaccinated can have now he's
on a mission
to change minds it's not fake i'm happy
to take care i think it's a good thing
uh i don't think there's much downfall
it's it's one of those things you weigh
out
the options and it sounds better to take
it than not to take it yeah
i would question you know the business
side of it
um and i guess you know
the pressure that the doctors received
you know to make the vaccine itself
have you been struck or surprised
by what you've seen when it comes to
vaccine hesitancy
honestly i wasn't that surprised i've
seen it myself
unfortunately i've seen people from the
black and asian community die
and even then some of their families
still are hesitant to take the vaccine
we're you know we're a part of two
pandemics it's pandemic and an epidemic
where information is
flying out the place and i think we have
to do more to crack on you know
misinformation
going around the internet because this
is what's scaring people mps don't agree
all the time but i'm taking the
vaccination issue we do
we know that some ethnic minority groups
are more likely to die from covid and
less likely to get the vaccine
herbert 19 has exploited the existing
inequalities in our society lenny henry
is not the first to make a direct appeal
i feel like we should all be doing our
part i'm glad i've been able to educate
you guys a bit
take-up among young black people in
particular is a looming test
the real success of our vaccine rollout
will depend on it
and hopefully obviously when you're
eligible you guys can get yours and we
can go back to living normal
for real thank you ali sky news
well we're joined this morning by the
business secretary quasi quarten good to
see you this morning i know we saw you
in that uh report we'll talk about that
issue the vaccine uptake issue
in just a moment but can we start by
looking at uh
this sort of a deal if you like to a
global cooperation to try to tackle
this and future pandemics i mean it
seems very impressive in one hou
on one hand but concerning on the other
when countries like the united states
don't seem to be joining up on it
i think it's a start i think it's really
important uh that we work
collaboratively uh internationally with
friends and partners and all countries
to deal with what after all
is a global problem the pandemic emerged
at the beginning of last year and has
caused huge amounts of devastation uh
it's set
uh economies back it's taken thousands
of lives
and i think it's absolutely the right
thing for us to work
internationally and cooperatively how
does that then tie in with
things like the vaccine i mean there's
been an awful lot of international
cooperation in
creating vaccines but obviously as we've
seen with our relationship with the eu
some problems when it comes to
distributing them
i think they've been a few uh problems
but generally what we've tried to do
in the uk is roll out the vaccine as
widely as possible
and we've had something like 30 million
people receive
the first dose which is more than half
the population
and we're working as well with the
european friends and allies
to try and make sure that their
populations are also vaccinated so
i don't think it's a it's a competitive
situation i think that's
an unfortunate way of looking at it so
where do we stand at the moment
considering we are doing so well in
general terms on
on the vaccine rollout in the uk where
do we stand on
sharing some of our supplies are we at a
point now
where we can start distributing to other
countries
i think our main focus at the moment is
to try and vaccinate
the whole adult population and we're
still away and there's still a way to go
on that
and also uh the other thing that we have
to stick to is of course the road map
and in order to
get the road map into order to reopen
the economy we've got to vaccinate
as many people in our country as
possible
what about somewhere like ireland which
we know is is in need of some doses and
in some respects our
our closest neighbor when can we start
helping ireland out i think our focus
has to be to try and keep
uh britain safe we want to work
cooperatively as well uh with other
countries but the main
priority is to get the vaccine rollout
let's just work through our vaccine
program
it's been quite successful this isn't
the time to let
up on it and then we can do uh we can go
through the road map and
and then if there is a cert if there are
surplus uh
vaccine doses then we can we can we can
share them but there are no surpluses at
the moment we've still got
a huge number to to vaccinate and where
does that leave us then in terms of the
the news about nova vacs and the fact
that the 60 million doses are being made
in the uk i mean i don't know how many
of those the uk is thinking
is the uk thinking of buying all of
those 60 million doses i mean what's the
process here
so we've got very clear targets and our
job is to try and source
uh as many uh vaccine doses as possible
and then once we've worked through the
population and vaccinated everybody
then we can think about uh what we're
going to do but our real focus at the
moment
is to try and uh see the end of the
vaccine roll out
so that we can make sure that we hit
those uh road map targets
and can reopen society and get back to a
normal life
an awful lot of people minister are
going to be watching this
and absolutely agreeing with you and
saying yeah we've got to sort ourselves
out first and there's a there's a lot of
logic to that
a lot of people can understand that but
it does seem to jar slightly
on the back of boris johnson saying yeah
we need a a global treaty on this
helping
obviously helping out countries who are
in a much worse position than ourselves
when we
we can't look after ourselves first and
be part of a global treaty helping
others at the same time can we
well we can because the letter was
mainly um focused
on future pandemics it's trying to work
out an international framework where
we can be more resilient as an
international community
for future outbreaks of disease
today we've got a crisis upon us and
it's absolutely right that we should be
focused
on trying to deal with that in our own
country and keeping our people safe
so that we can get back to a normal uh
way of life
in terms of keeping our people safe when
we saw you in that video that selena
henry's fronting about
you know getting to the you know really
trying to get the message through to the
black community to
to take the vaccine
why is there so much hesitancy do you
think in some parts of the black
community
i think there's a possibly a degree of
uh misinformation
people share things on social media uh i
think
uh there's a awareness uh sometimes
but what i would say on that is that i
think at the beginning of the vaccine
process there was a lot more
uh skepticism amongst certain
communities
here in the uk than there is today i
think we've made great strides actually
and there's still a way to go but i
think there's been a huge improvement
and a huge increase in uptake uh amongst
uh
vulnerable communities and amongst uh
the ama communities as well
but but it says a lot doesn't it that
there are yeah
there is an element of mistrust of the
authorities
amongst black communities if we use that
as
an example you know that opens up a
wider picture doesn't it as to
how we need to tackle that problem and
that mistrust in governance
absolutely i mean i think that you know
people do um
are skeptical i think we've got we've
got a job as government as
political leaders to reach out to as
many people in this country
as possible the coronavirus doesn't
discriminate
between people i think we're all very
vulnerable
to it and we have a job to do to
convince people that this is
the safe way to go and i think there has
been progress made
i saw the video that you showed uh and
lenny henry and others
from the black and asian community uh
we're
making that message very clear and i
think that's a good thing and we've got
to keep
uh saying the message it is incumbent on
people like yourself
isn't it as well to um and to not only
sort of stand
proud in government if you like her in
politics but you've got to also play a
crucial role presumably moving forward
and getting
more people from ethnic minority
backgrounds or black backgrounds to
actually really get involved in politics
absolutely you're absolutely right and
that's why i took part in the video
and as there were many other people in
that video from different political
parties it was diane abbott
uh there was uh dawn butler i was on the
video there were people from
uh you know the entertainment uh acting
all sorts of
different professions who were trying to
make their their voice heard and
encouraging people
vitally to take up the the vaccine and
that's that's absolutely the right thing
i mean you've talked about you know the
importance of of of getting the vaccine
because it's going to help us get back
to normal i know you've written a letter
alongside the chancellor today
you call 2021 um the
let me get the phrase right the the year
of economic recovery now
that sounds great some people are going
to say is it perhaps a little bit
ambitious
at this stage what are you hoping to put
in place to make sure that we can see an
economic recovery this year
i think the most important thing the the
the quickest route towards
economic recovery is really vaccine roll
out and making sure that we hit those
uh milestones on the road map so we've
got april the 12th coming up
we've got may the 17th and then by june
the 21st we want to be in a position
where
we can essentially go back to normal all
the restrictions will be eased
we're very focused on that and the way
to get there not only through vaccine
roll out but also looking at the data
and the data that we've seen is quite
encouraging
the numbers of deaths thankfully has
gone down
quite considerably the hospitalization
rate is also going down
and the infection rate is going down and
so we're looking at all those
uh metrics all that all that data and
we're trying to stick
as closely as we can uh to the dates in
the roadmap and as far as i can see as
far as the prime minister can see in the
data that we're looking at
there's no reason to think we can't hit
those dates now if we
succeed in hitting those dates there's
no doubt to me that uh
economic recovery is really possible
because shops will be open
people will be going back to normal life
economic activity in this country will
resume and
there's every prospect that 2021 will be
a much uh more prosperous
successful year than 2020 was but
what about a more targeted recovery
because people get into habits we know
that we're
we're all shopping online at the moment
there's been this call for the
shop out to help out for these sort of
very small uh
businesses on the high street who were
just selling through
you know the the the their shops not
selling online
and would a scheme like that in your
view
help bring us back to the high street
and help keep these small businesses
alive
we're always looking at policies and
ways in which we can
regenerate the economy and drive growth
i think our focus at the moment is
really to deal with the pandemic
uh yes it is true that the numbers are
going down
but as we've seen in europe there was a
there's a third wave there there all
sorts of risks out there that we have to
be
robust against so that's where the focus
is we want to drive down
those numbers and we want to gradually
open up the economy as was outlined
in the prime minister's roadmap and i
think that's really where
our focus is at the moment can i ask you
about
former prime minister david cameron who
said it was it's just after the expenses
scandal
i think when he said lobbying political
lobbying was the next big scandal
waiting to happen now he's at the center
of controversy
over the the green sill corporation
do the rules need to change look i think
people have looked
uh at this uh as far as i know
david cameron did absolutely nothing uh
wrong he was a public servant for a long
time
uh he's now gone into private life and
is
was working for uh green cell capital
people have looked into
uh his role uh people looked into the
the fact that
uh he may or may not have contacted uh
people officials in the treasury uh
as as far as i know everything was uh
above board
he's been largely exonerated and
i think we should just move on but
sir alistair graham a former chair of
the standards committee he's calling
for an inquiry now and there certainly
seems to be
it could be argued a lack of
transparency as to exactly what's going
on i mean green sill for example seems
to be having
some someone described it as a free run
of whitehall between 2012 and 2015 when
david cameron was still prime minister
well obviously sir as to graham's uh
committee i mean can look into
uh exactly uh what they want i think
that there's been a lot of transparency
actually there's been a lot of
information
about what david cameron uh what he said
uh who he contacted to within the
treasury i think they've been very open
about
about what's happened uh and i think
that lack of transparency
i don't think is a problem in this case
but isn't there an argument
if you want a clean sweep on this a
clean line stop
former politicians and former prime
ministers from going into those lobbying
jobs at least for
a period of time after they come out of
of office
wouldn't that be a possible way forward
i think there are rules i think
uh david cameron as far as i remember
was recruited in 2018
two years after uh he'd left downing
street
uh and i think that was an appreciable
length of time
what we can't do i guess go down the
route of
banning people from from making a living
pursuing a profession long after they've
left uh
political life okay minister good to
talk to you this morning thank you
well political correspondent kate mccann
was listening into all that can we
can we start with this lobbying issue
because it seems like this is a question
which is
going to build over the next few days
because there are questions about what
goes on and the
some of the murky dealings in the
corridors of power
and the propriety of former prime
ministers and the way that they have
access and actually this isn't just
about david cameron as a former prime
minister it's about his role when he was
in government too i think quasi-cuatang
is a little bit hopeful perhaps there in
his response to you by saying that
people have looked into it because
while there has been some investigation
there are many many questions
outstanding
and now quite significant calls actually
for a proper standards committee to look
into this and to really just see
whether everything was done above board
particularly when it comes to spending
public money on some of those contracts
i think that's where the biggest
questions are
whether it was value for money and
whether actually the public press was
ever put at risk so
there is still more to go on that one i
think yeah because as i said to the
minister there are these
these reports of of lex green sill the
man involved here sort of
having free run of whitehall in that
three-year period up to 2015.
yeah and some questions about the way
that recommendations were made to those
people who make decisions you know about
this company about how it was working
about how effective it was
perhaps even a suggestion that maybe
civil servants had warned against it and
that the recommendations had actually
been changed so
you know there is a long way to go it's
important to say clearly david cameron
hasn't actually
commented formally on this issue yet
there are many many calls as i said from
the labour party
just one of them to do a proper
investigation i think there is still
some way to go some questions for the
current government actually still to
answer on that issue
okay okay thank you well at half past
seven this morning we're going to be
joined by professor paul heath he's the
chief investigator of the uk
novavax trial as the prime minister
announces
up to 60 million doses of the as yet
unapproved
vaccine will be manufactured in the uk
to mark autism awareness week at half
nine this morning we're joined by bobby
tranley the top
racer at team brit that
is making motorsport accessible to
people with disabilities
and the highest of the highs and the
lowest of the lows
we'll talk to record-breaking vanessa
o'brien
who became the first woman to climb
everest and
go as far down the mariana trench as you
can go
that's at 9 45.
now the trial of derrick chauvin the
police officer accused of murdering
george floyd continues today yesterday
protesters gathered peacefully outside
the court to demand justice
sally lockwood reports from minneapolis
[Applause]
protests around the trial have been
peaceful but persistent
the first day ended with more calls for
justice for george floyd
but there's a hope here it will
represent a turning point in history
before the jury former officer derek
shovin heard the prosecution's case
that george floyd would not have died
were it not
for his actions the video of him
restraining george floyd was their
exhibit a
27 cries that he couldn't breathe
prosecutors arguing derek chauvin had
nearly 10 minutes
to think about what he was doing you
will learn
that on may 25th of 2020
mr derrick chavin betrayed this badge
when he used excessive and unreasonable
force
upon the body of mr george floyd
that he put his knees upon his neck and
his back
grinding and crushing him until
the very breath no ladies and gentlemen
until the very life
were squeezed out of him new footage
showed an initial struggle to pull
george floyd to the ground but what then
unfolded
so concerned a 9-1-1 dispatcher
she told the court she called the police
on the police involved
the defense though argued george floyd's
condition was down to drugs
and a heart condition you will learn
that derek sheldon did exactly what he
had been trained to do
over the course of his 19-year career
the use of force is not attractive
but it is a necessary component of
policing
the floyd family lawyer ben crump
expected the defense to seek to
discredit george floyd's character
but he told me if he'd been a white
american
no one would say this is a hard case to
consider
it is because george floyd is an
african-american
and historically police officers are not
held accountable
for killing black people unjustifiably
in america
that's why everybody is saying this is
your opportunity america
to show us that you are the beacon
of hope and justice when it comes to
equality and justice fall
george floyd's death mobilized millions
in protest
worldwide but any hope this trial may be
a chance for change
[Music]
is in the hands of 12 jurors sally
lockwood sky
news minneapolis well sky news will have
full coverage of the trial
continuous coverage of the court
proceedings streaming live on our
website and app
on youtube and a special pop-up channel
which is on sky
524 we'll get full coverage of course
throughout the day
here on sky news
now looking at some of the other main
stories for you this morning and
china has sharply reduced the number of
directly elected seats in hong kong's
legislature in a setback for the
democracy movement
in the new makeup the legislative
legislature
will be expanded to 90 seats with only
20
directly elected by the public
young people will increasingly bear the
brunt of the unemployment crisis after
the pandemic
that's according to research from the
prince's trust and the
learning and work institute they say
younger workers are underrepresented in
the sectors of the economy
most likely to recover for the second
year in a row
road organizations are predicting
there'll be no easter getaway this year
the aaa says only 28 of drivers will be
on the road easter monday which is
normally
one of the busiest days of the year
thailand is reported to be sending some
of the thousands of refugees who've
crossed its border
back to their homes in myanmar they fled
following airstrikes at the weekend as a
military crackdown
continues after a coup last month our
southeast asia correspondent
siobhan robbins reports from the border
between thailand
and myanmar
in myanmar slingshots against bullets
junta forces have killed more than 450
people
air strikes over the weekend forcing
thousands from their homes
while some fled to the nearby forest
many others crossed the border to
thailand
hoping for refuge this group of men
women and children
are among them but activists say the
protection they sought has been denied
they claim more than 2 000 have been
sent back
to the homes they ran from we've got a
whole new generation
of grandchildren who are having to flee
to hide in the jungle
trying to escape into thailand and being
forced back again
it's a cycle that seems to be unending
and there doesn't seem to be any
willingness from
thailand or the rest of the
international community to try to
take the firm kind of action to end this
cycle
the thai authorities denied any such
pushback
and said they would continue to look
after refugees
the prime minister said earlier the
country was preparing to accept them
please let this be an internal issue for
us we don't want to have an exodus of
refugees
or even evacuations into our territory
but we will observe human rights too
our path to the refugees was blocked
thai military saying
access was restricted due to covert 19.
but locals told us they believe more
people are preparing
to cross the border the bank on the far
side of the river there
is in myanmar so for people who are
running for their lives
thailand is tantalizingly close but not
all
routes here are safe we're told the
buildings on the top of that hill
are an army base belonging to the
myanmar military
but as the death toll in myanmar
continues to mount
people will look for anywhere they can
find safety
siobhan robbins sky news on the thai
border
well this is sky news breakfast let's
have a check on the weather now
with our nas good morning what have you
got for us today nas
hi al steven um it's looking sunny fine
and dry for
many areas today in fact yesterday we
saw the highest temperature of the year
so far
today we're likely to beat it
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning plenty of spring warmth out
there for today in fact some more than
spring warmth as temperatures
are likely to be above average for the
time of year once again this time of the
year we
usually see highs around 12 degrees
celsius in the south and around seven or
eight in the north
but today we're likely to be way above
that
around the early 20s across many parts
of england and wales and in the high
teens
further north and west to begin with
those a chilly start across most of
england and
wales frosty with some patches of mist
and fog over the south and west
cloudier elsewhere with a few spots of
rain and heavy and persistent rain
across the northwest of scotland once
again
and that rain will persist across the
northwest of scotland this afternoon
still some heavy downpours particularly
across western parts of scotland where
there's the risk of flooding that rain
has been there for the last few days
whereas across the south and east of
scotland as well as across ireland and
northern ireland there will be mostly
cloudy skies but there will be some good
spells of sunshine developing this
afternoon the sunshine will continue
across england and wales again as i said
temperatures will be widely into the
early 20s
into the high teens further north and
west and still above average where
it will be wet across the northwest of
scotland but of course it will feel cool
under the wet and windy conditions there
locally we could see highs of 23 degrees
at celsius in the
southeast somewhere around the london
cambridgeshire norfolk area
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
nurse thank you still to come on sky
news breakfast we're going to talk to
the man in charge of the novavax trial
after news the uk has signed a deal on
doses
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten front line
they are dying here
boys we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
home
i can't believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it
the mission behind my work is to try and
use food stories
to get behind the headlines because i
think we can all agree
food is such a great unifier and um
there's this old proverb that i really
love
that's uh an enemy is just a person
whose story you haven't heard yet
and for me food is such a great way to
get into people's stories and that's
what inspired me to write
my book the book really's got kind of
two purposes
one look in a year that realistically
we're probably not going to get off on
for on a foreign holiday it kind of
enables you to go on a little vicarious
trip through your kitchen like today i'm
just cooking some nice turkish
eggs and lovely men and men but also the
book explores the stories
of lots of refugees and migrants that i
met throughout the eastern mediterranean
so we're talking about greece turkey and
cyprus and it really tries to explore
what borders and migration mean in an
interconnected world because
you know borders and migration have just
dominated the headlines haven't they
both here with brexit
you know across the atlantic with trump
i wanted to get behind that and try and
use
food stories to show the human face of
people who need to move
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
i'm greg milam skye's u.s correspondent
here in los
angeles
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well this is sky news breakfast our main
news this morning and the prime minister
is one of 24 world
leaders to sign a treaty calling on
countries to work
together in any future pandemic the
letter urges nations to share medicines
and vaccines but earlier
i asked the business secretary whether
the uk was ready in this pandemic
to share any of its vaccine supply
i think our focus has to be to try and
keep britain
safe we want to work cooperatively as
well with other countries but the main
priority is to get the vaccine rollout
let's just work through our vaccine
program
uh it's been quite successful this isn't
the time uh to let
up on it and then we can do uh we can go
through the roadmap and and then if
there is a cert if there are surplus uh
vaccine doses then we can we can we can
share them but there are no surpluses at
the moment we've still got
a huge number to to vaccinate well let's
have a look at the latest coronavirus
data
for you and four thousand six hundred
and fifty four new covid19
reported in the most recent 24-hour
period
with 23 more deaths across the uk
that takes a total number of people
who've died to 126
615 the latest figures also show
that 30.4 million first doses of a
vaccine
have now been given well the prime
minister last night announced that 60
million doses
of the novavax vaccine are to be
produced
and packaged in england the prime
minister said the jabs will be bottled
at the glaxosmithkline
facility in barnard castle novavac
say the jab is effective against the
kent variant but it's yet to be approved
by the uk regulator well let's talk to
the uk
novovax trial chief investigator and
director
of the vaccine institute at st george's
university
of london professor paul heath good to
see you this morning
where are we in terms of nova vacs and
how close it
is or is potentially to getting approved
uh well the uh obviously that the trial
has uh produced the
primary results and this shows very high
efficacy as you've said
against symptomatic covert 19
around 90 effective and that includes
against the uk variant around 86 percent
effective against the uk variant
around 95 percent effective against the
previous
uh so-called uh wuhan strain variant so
really excellent data and also showing
very high
levels of safety no no no safety
concerns
so all of this now is with the mhra
and uh of course they are diligently
uh looking at all of the data and will
in in good time uh hopefully uh approve
this vaccine
uh to be implemented and we uh you know
and on behalf of all of the
investigators who have done so much
work in getting this uh trial to where
it is and
the more than fifteen thousand
participants who took part in it
we're all very keen of course for it to
be approved and then
implemented rapidly in the uk uh where
are we in terms of of actually
how how this is this is delivered to us
are we looking at a double dose a single
dose oh so this is a two dose
schedule so two doses given 21 days
apart
is how it's been done in the trial uh
and
that i would imagine would be the way it
is implemented of course
in the uk we we take into consideration
a range of other
factors when considering the the
schedule for a vaccine as we've seen
with the
extending up to 12 weeks for the pfizer
and the astrazeneca vaccine so
i think it will depend on on what is
happening at the time
the vaccine uh comes to be implemented
uh
in terms of what the schedule will be
will that will be used but as i say it
was a three week schedule
in the trial that would that we have
done would it still be effective on a
12-week timetable
uh look you know the answer is we don't
know because we haven't looked at
uh studies uh where the two doses have
been given
uh separated by more than uh three to
four weeks
from a basic immunological principles i
think it probably would be i mean it is
a
um a subunit protein adjuvant vaccine so
it's
vaccine technology that we're actually
quite familiar with there are
a range of other vaccines that we
routinely use
that are similarly made so the influenza
vaccine is a subunit protein
adjuvant vaccine for example and we know
from other vaccines that we can
extend the interval between doses and
do so with confidence so if if we needed
to
for this vaccine i'm sure extending that
interval would be
fine from the point of view of its
effectiveness yes
a lot of the effectiveness data that
we've seen in the past and i don't want
to get too involved in some of the
figures because it just get a bit
confusing
but a lot of it focuses on on its
effectiveness in
various age groups now of course the the
the older
uh population and the clinically
vulnerable have been
of most concern but we're heading to a
point now where it is the
the younger end of the population who
are still to be vaccinated
so does that impressive data that you
came out with before
does that still apply to those what
under 50
oh very much so i think what we've shown
with this vaccine is that it is
effective
in all ages obviously that the concern
that we
have as you've said is whether these
vaccines are effective
in the highest risk groups particularly
the elderly
and this vaccine certainly is as indeed
all of the other vaccines that have now
been approved they're all showing high
levels
of efficacy uh against uh disease in the
elderly as well as in those who have
a range of other underlying health
conditions so this is great news
i mean looking at a broader picture just
away from your sort of direct role if
you like with with novavax
why is it important that we've got all
these different vaccines out there now
moderna which we
we don't have in this country but the
astrazeneca the pfizer
the novovax some people will inevitably
say well why do we need so many
different vaccines
yeah well obviously because there are so
many people that need to be vaccinated
so we need to have
a a huge supply of vaccine in order to
fully vaccinate our population so that
that i think is the basic
reason there are other things that may
be shown between the different vaccines
ultimately so it may be shown for
example that certain vaccines
are more appropriate for certain groups
for the elderly
uh for those with underlying health
problems uh
and and so on and i think in in time it
may be that we
we define different groups for different
vaccines
we are uh for example contemplating
vaccinating
uh adolescents and children we're
contemplating
and indeed vaccinating pregnant women
and it may be that studies will show as
i say that certain vaccines
are perhaps better suited to different
groups so to have this
range of vaccines using a range of
different technologies available
is allows us to ultimately refine
the vaccine program the next bit of
course will be the booster doses so
we we've already heard over the weekend
a proposal that boosts the doses
will be um considered and implemented
potentially
uh later this year and it may be that
different vaccines are better suited
to be booster doses so so again having a
whole range of different vaccines using
different vaccine technologies allows us
as i say to refine the program that we
have at the moment
and what's your understanding of what is
going to happen to the 60 million doses
that the prime minister
was talking about they're being
manufactured and packaged
in the uk but i mean is your
understanding that they they are
intended for use in the uk
are they to go elsewhere well i i'm
afraid i don't have any insight into
that
um i'm sure the intention of course is
to
uh implement those vaccines in the uk at
least initially
um and and that's what we would really
like to see because this has really been
tested in the uk population
but i think in going to your previous
story uh you know i i think
uh the more that we vaccinate our
population and the more vaccine doses
that we have
it means that there will be doses that
we can
then send to other countries that need
it because we
after all do need to vaccinate the world
and i think
as soon as we have done um the priority
groups in the uk we should be
um contemplating uh sending
spare doses to to those countries who
are not in the same fortunate position
that we are
so potentially ultimately doses will
notice of the novovax vaccine will go
to other countries but the first
priority of course will be to complete
the vaccine rollout in the uk
and and i'm sure novovack's vaccine will
be contributing
um to toward that aim i know it's a
slightly difficult one for various
reasons
but i want to talk about costs just
briefly if i can i know you probably
haven't got the exact figures
with you it may not be in your remit but
where does it fall within the general
sort of cost scale because obviously the
astrazeneca vaccine
was much much much cheaper than pfizer i
mean
where does this lie on the scale well
you're right it's not within my
um my remit or indeed my knowledge but
uh
from what i'm aware it's all somewhere
between
the the astrazeneca uh and
the more expensive pfizer and modern
vaccines
but but look i think you know cost is
something which
uh depends on a range of factors and so
uh it may be
it may be quite quite different to that
and of course
i and we we have no idea what the uk
government has
has paid for this vaccine yeah okay well
we won't hold you to that professor
heath good to talk to you this morning
thank you
thank you very much well sky news has
seen a draft report of the world health
organization's findings into the origins
of covid 19. let's talk to our asia
correspondent
tom cheshire who joins us now so
what does it say tom
it says pretty much what we've already
heard a lot of it's very very similar to
the findings we heard when we went down
to wuhan the press conference they held
at the end
of the four-week trip there is a few
more details in there you see some
behind-the-scenes negotiations they
started in july last year
trying to get access to china and then
when the who team arrived in china their
visits were strictly controlled
scheduled prepared in advance so
questions really about how much they're
able to do more than a year
after the pandemic uh first arose in
wuhan in hubei province
um but the main thing is we still don't
know where kovid 19
came from we've got some theories now
the most likely theory according to the
who report is that
it came from a bat to another animal not
yet
identified and then into humans the
thing it dismisses as least likely
is the idea that it came from a
laboratory there are several
virus laboratories in wuhan there have
been speculation that kovid19 might have
escaped they think this is
extremely unlikely but they haven't
ruled it out
so the question is what happens next if
we don't know where we are the who
remains
recommends all sorts of questions for
further studies some of those
would have to take place in china i
think now it's going from the scientific
to the
geopolitical actually it was already
pretty political for the scientific
stage
and china will see its work as done it
thinks it's being transparent and it's
challenging
other countries including the us in
particular to let the who
into their laboratories into their
countries to investigate the origins
because they still think
it might have originated outside of
china so the scientific work is done i
think we're going to get back into the
rows
over the origins of covert 19 in a very
geopolitical manner
okay tom for now thank you well still to
come on sky news breakfast i'm going to
be joined by the southern africa
director of human rights watch about the
ongoing situation in mozambique
following an islamist attack at the
weekend
peaceful revolutions violent revolutions
growing revolutions
this was going to be a massive moment
there was nothing like the arab spring
there's so many different places so
chaotic
freedom's a whole lot different to
democracy
okay let's go for it i'm really worried
about being here that year changed
everything
world politics the landscape it
certainly changed
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely
thin and very frail
the people here are praying quietly to
themselves
i'm alex crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in istanbul
[Music]
now they're trying to finish the job off
so they can move
[Music]
they're becoming very sensitive about
having the media around
they have no protective masks or
protective equipment
at all we aim to be the best and the
most
trusted place in the world every time
they touch and they
spray sprayed spray
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
[Music]
very difficult for these firefighters to
get a grip of it and get on top of it
and put it out
i can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge lake
[Music]
for the early beyond the risers
for the knowledge seekers welcome to
divided states
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertainment
podcast
but wherever you are welcome to safety
holiday podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all that politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news story
cast
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know that air pollution
isn't just bad for the environment it's
bad for our health too
[Music]
there will be widespread sunshine and
warmth across england and wales today
and most of ireland
northern ireland and the south and east
of scotland will be fine and warm with
bright or sunny spells developing
however the northwest of scotland will
be cold with outbreaks of rain
heaviest and most persistent over
western scotland
so taking a look at the air pollution
levels on a scale of 1 to 10 with 10
being very high most places will stay at
a low level of 1 to 3 again
however some isolated pockets of
moderate air pollution may persist in
northern scotland
and the northern isles the air quality
report
sponsored by phillips air purifiers
a british man is understood to be
missing after an islamist attack on a
town in the north of mozambique in which
dozens of people were killed the
province of cabo delgado where the
attack took place has been the target of
islamist insurgency for a couple of
years leaving thousands of people
displaced well let's talk to darya
mavinga
southern africa director at human rights
watch good to see you this morning look
can you put some sort of context on this
for us and
and who we're talking about carrying out
this attack
well there is an islamist
armed group that is locally known as
al-shabab
but is unrelated to the somalia
al-shabab uh it
is also known by different names it has
been
carrying out attacks in the north of
mozambique
since october 2017 it has carried out
actually more than 570 attacks
uh resulting in killings of more than
2000 people and
displacements or for more than 600 000
people in cabo delgado province and it
is this group that was responsible since
last wednesday
for an attack on palmer town uh that
resulted in the killing
of dozens of people including seven
people were killed
as they were trying to escape in a
convoy
uh to run away from the fighting
in powers town do we know why this group
is
particularly targeting that province
well not much is known because they are
not saying much about their motives and
what they want but uh cabo dogada
province
has got a multi-billion dollar
natural gas projects that are ongoing
there including
one run by uh french
gas giant total so that is a part of
perhaps why there is so much fighting uh
from this particular group but um the
mozambique authorities i have not opened
up the province
for investigators and researchers and
journalists so it's very difficult to
get
precise and accurate information about
what is going on
and why this group is uh
carrying out these attacks in in
northern mozambique
i mean presumably the lifeing in cabo
delgado must be extremely
difficult if you save as you say two and
a half thousand deaths
or thereabouts and seven hundred
thousand people
displaced i mean life must be absolutely
miserable there at the moment
absolutely in fact it is a massive
humanitarian crisis that is there now uh
hundreds of thousands of thousands
really are out
and they need uh support they
have moved further south to pemba which
is um
a bit quieter now and are living in
camps and some have actually
walked up northwards across into
tanzania the neighboring country so it
is at a chaos and people are living in
fear
and um there is no security and the most
american authorities have not come
forward
uh with a solution to guarantee uh the
safety of civilians in cabo delgado
i mean does there need to be more of an
international effort on this i mean it's
something
a lot of us just weren't aware of who's
going on for the last four years
is it now time for the international
community to mobilize on this
absolutely the time is actually overdue
for the international community to
mobilize for this and also
unfortunately the regional community the
southern african development community
and the african union have not
prioritized this crisis
uh it is escalating the attacks are
intensifying
becoming more sophisticated uh and
indeed
there is no need for the international
community to come together to ensure
that
this is brought to an end otherwise
there is a huge risk
that it could spread to other parts of
southern africa very quickly
okay dara good to talk to you this
morning thank you
this is sky news breakfast let's have a
look at the weather for you
with nats
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning once again we're looking at
mostly fine and dry conditions across
the vast majority of the uk and island
it is going to be widely warm with
temperatures above average
pretty much everywhere this time of the
year we'd expect to see highs around 12
degrees celsius across the south and
around 8 degrees celsius in the north
but we're widely going to see
temperatures top up to around 20 to 21
degrees celsius over england and wales
possibly up to 23 degrees celsius
somewhere in the southeast
and in the high teens across ireland
northern ireland to the south and east
of scotland
more in the way of cloud across these
areas but there will still be brighter
sunny spells
widespread sunshine for ireland england
and wales later after a chilly start
but the northwest of scotland remains
cool and very wet there
the weather sponsored by qatar airways